good morning Hank it's Monday February
14 2011 I recently saw a youtuber I like
a lot name that I do
internet play a game called chubby bunny
Hank the rules are you just eat
marshmallows and say chubby bunny it's
pretty easy watch me chubby bunny chubby
bunny this is almost too easy
chubby bunny chubby bunny look up much
taller chubby bunny
this one is going to record the
challenge Hank :
well sucking glass our 14th with a
little dozen how are you doing it's
Valentine's Day isn't it Hank
crap ok Hank I have to go to the mall
walk with me ok so three things I hate
about Valentine's Day number one all
gift-giving is economically inefficient
but Valentine's Day is the worst because
you almost always give people stuff they
wouldn't choose to own themselves like
candy hearts or the necklace that my
wife colloquially refers to as boobs and
butt actually I should probably just get
her that necklace instead I am buying
her shampoo good lord Hank I've
purchased cars that cost less than that
shampoo secondly Valentine's Day is
perhaps the most potent symbol of our
weird obsession with romantic love like
why isn't best friends day the biggest
shopping day of the year because for
some reason we think you can only have
loving sustained relationships with
someone who you also sleep with if you
spend your life singularly obsessed with
romantic love you're going to miss out
on a lot of what's fun about being a
person also you're gonna have to spend a
lot of money on diamonds lastly I like
holidays that celebrate service or
sacrifice historical figures who
embodied our values but I don't really
see the point of a holiday that
celebrates romantic love I mean if you
need to be reminded to like your
romantic partner you're doing it wrong
Hank suppose like until the only good
thing about Valentine's Day is that
gift-giving while it is economically
inefficient is also kind of an act of
empathy right you have to imagine what
it's like to be someone else imagine
what they would want and then get it for
them but if I'm really being empathetic
Hank I'll recognized what the Yeti wants
most of all for Valentine's Day is not
hastily purchased toiletries but for me
to have this video finished and uploaded
by the time she gets home from work so
I'm gonna get on that Hank by the way
great job with your pants is the
sentence I never thought I'd say I'll
see you
pS Hank green noted American blog
brother just did a very funny
Valentine's Day truth or fail click
anywhere on the screen to go to that
click now you're not missing anything
best wishes